J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonsoir, ravi de vous retrouver. On est déjà le 9 mai, ce qui signifie qu'il ne reste plus qu'un petit mois avant les élections fédérales, régionales et européennes ici, en Belgique.
Et je termine aujourd'hui mon petit tour, du coup, du paysage politique belge francophone avec le Mouvement Réformateur.
Le dernier grand parti qui n'était pas encore venu dans Septante Minutes Avec cette saison. Et pour ce faire, mon invitée n'est autre que Valérie Glatigny.
C'est parti. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec Valérie Glatigny. Bonjour Valérie.
Bonjour monsieur Hachez.
Vous êtes originaire de la province de Luxembourg, du côté de Marche-en-Famenne. Vous êtes à l'origine philosophe de formation et journaliste pendant un temps, sur Must FM ?
Must FM, oui, oui, oui.
Must FM, voilà, dans la province de Luxembourg.
Et on vous connaît principalement parce que vous avez été ministre de 2019 à 2023, ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur,
de la Promotion sociale, de la Recherche scientifique, des Hôpitaux universitaires, de l'Aide à la jeunesse, des Maisons de justice, de la Promotion de Bruxelles, de la Jeunesse et du Sport. Fameux portefeuille
que vous avez opéré durant quatre ans, donc. Si on revient à l'origine de votre histoire, donc, je le disais, dans la province de Luxembourg, elle a commencé par une longue rencontre avec Louis Michel en 2003.
Oui, c'est vrai.
Durant laquelle vous avez apparemment eu des atomes crochus. Est-ce que vous pouvez me raconter ?
Oui, c'est vrai, il venait faire une conférence en province de Luxembourg et donc j'étais venue l'écouter et j'ai eu un genre de coup de foudre idéologique.
Il était contre l'entrée en guerre contre l'Irak parce qu'il estimait qu'il n'y avait pas de preuve d'existence d'armes de destruction massive.
Et il se fait qu'il avait raison. Hein, maintenant, on sait que c'est tout à fait correct. Et donc j'ai admiré son courage politique et on a commencé à discuter.
Et puis il m'avait proposé de lui envoyer son CV, ce que j'ai fait. Et puis j'ai en effet travaillé aux Affaires étrangères belges pendant un certain temps avant de le suivre à la Commission européenne et puis au Parlement européen.
Et donc c'est une longue histoire de compagnonnage idéologique qui a commencé en effet en 2003.
Ok, et donc c'est vraiment suite à une rencontre, atomes crochus et, parce que, donc, les études de philosophie, généralement, sont pas celles avec le plus de débouchés.
Et vous avez réussi à vous retrouver donc au Parlement européen.
Oui, j'ai fait les études qui me passionnaient. Je me suis dit que c'était ça qui était le plus important. C'est ce que je conseille toujours aux étudiants.
Bien sûr, il faut avoir le soin de l'insertion socioprofessionnelle après. Donc moi, j'ai également fait un diplôme ensuite en éthique biomédicale pour pouvoir travailler dans cette spécialisation.
Et c'est d'ailleurs via cette spécialisation que j'ai rencontré Louis Michel, puisque c'était l'époque des réformes éthiques lancées par le gouvernement Verhofstadt.
Et donc on a travaillé ensemble sur toute une série de questions éthiques : l'euthanasie, la gestation pour autrui, etc.
Donc toute une série de thèmes qui étaient mis à l'avant-plan politique à ce moment-là.
Et donc, vous expliquez que la question européenne est une grande passion pour vous.
Oui.
En 2019, après donc quinze, seize ans de travail au Parlement européen, vous vous retrouvez première suppléante MR aux Européennes et vous obtenez plus de dix-neuf mille voix de préférence.
Et vous, à la grande surprise de tout le monde, vous vous retrouvez nommée au gouvernement de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles.
Comment est-ce que c'est arrivé ? C'était une surprise pour vous aussi ?
Oui, c'était ma propre surprise puisque je ne savais pas du tout que j'étais ministrable. J'avais repris mon travail au Parlement européen puisque effectivement, c'est mon travail principal.
Et d'ailleurs, j'en profite pour attirer l'attention sur l'intérêt pour un politique d'avoir déjà une vie professionnelle vers laquelle on peut à nouveau se tourner si, par exemple, un mandat s'achève.
Je trouve ça très sain de pouvoir avoir une vie professionnelle antérieure et une vie professionnelle vers laquelle on peut encore se tourner quand un mandat s'achève.
C'est ce que vous avez fait cette année d'ailleurs.
Oui, tout à fait. J'ai eu un problème médical et ça m'a permis de reprendre langue avec ma passion qui est effectivement, qui sont les affaires européennes.
Et c'est vrai que ce travail m'a apporté énormément de choses et je me suis dit : je suis à un moment où je comprends en effet bien les thèmes européens et je voudrais pouvoir les porter en mon nom propre.
Je trouvais qu'il y avait toute une série de choses qui étaient systématiquement renvoyées d'une législature à l'autre sans qu'on trouve jamais de solution, au premier rang desquels, bien sûr, aussi la question migratoire
qui plombe chaque campagne électorale européenne.
Et donc j'étais vraiment en capacité, me semblait-il, de pouvoir
porter un projet au niveau européen, ce que j'ai fait. Et puis, en effet, j'ai reçu ces coups de fil puisque je ne répondais pas au départ, j'étais partie promener mes chiens, donc,
je n'avais pas répondu aux appels parce que c'était en effet une surprise pour moi aussi.
Et donc ensuite, j'ai pris quelques jours, quelques semaines pour étudier les dossiers et pouvoir développer une politique pour toutes les neuf compétences que vous avez mentionnées.
C'est vrai que c'était un
mandat vraiment passionnant. Ça a été un crève-cœur de ne pas pouvoir
le poursuivre jusqu'au bout, puisqu'après quatre années de mandat, alors que les principales réformes étaient faites et il ne restait plus quelque part qu'à
les vendre, eh bien, j'ai eu un problème médical qui m'a conduit à démissionner pour pouvoir me consacrer à ma convalescence.
Et donc maintenant que je suis complètement rétablie, l'idée, c'est de nouveau pouvoir porter un projet politique.
Vous revendiquez également pleinement le fait d'être féministe. Quelles sont les figures qui vous ont inspiré au niveau de ce combat féministe ?
Dans le jeu des sept familles du féminisme, vous appartenez à quelle famille ?
Moi, j'ai toujours été fascinée par quelqu'un qui est sur ma liste, c'est Viviane Teitelbaum. Elle parlait des droits des femmes quand personne n'en parlait, quand c'était pas sexy.
Maintenant, c'est mainstream. Mais il faut se souvenir que Viviane, elle porte ce combat depuis plus de vingt-cinq ans. Et donc c'est vrai que c'est quelqu'un qui m'a beaucoup inspirée.
Bien sûr, le fait que mon parti ait désigné Sophie Wilmès comme première Premier ministre en Belgique, ça a été déterminant.
Et puis moi, quand je suis arrivée à la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, ben, il y avait six recteurs hommes. Donc ça a bien changé depuis.
Il y avait aussi des présidents de fédérations sportives, puisque j'étais aussi ministre des Sports. Eh bien, sur, je sais plus, je pense qu'il y en avait septante, je pense qu'il y avait soixante-huit hommes, je pense, quelque chose comme ça. Donc-
Et vous avez imposé la présence de au moins trente-trois pour cent de femmes dans les conseils d'administration des fédérations sportives.
Exactement. Maximum deux tiers de personnes du même sexe dans les conseils d'administration. Et donc on voit qu'il y a une amélioration notable.
Mais c'est vrai que jusqu'ici, il y avait la présidente de la Fédération gymnastique qui était une femme ou la Fédération de danse.
Et puis après, tous les autres, c'était des hommes. Et donc c'est quelque chose qu'on a fait avec les présidents eux-mêmes.
On l'a pas fait contre eux. Eux-mêmes se rendent compte que ce sont les équipes mixtes qui performent le mieux. Et donc on a fait ça avec eux, en les accompagnant.
Et on a évidemment un mécanisme de sanction qu'on n'a pas encore dû actionner jusqu'ici, parce que je pense qu'ils se rendent compte et ils sont eux-mêmes les acteurs de changement.
Vous citiez à l'instant Sophie Wilmès. C'est quelqu'un qui, à chaque fois qu'on lui rappelle qu'elle est la première femme Premier ministre ou qu'elle a occupé un rôle important en tant que première femme de quoi que ce soit,
elle a tendance à vouloir changer de sujet, à ne pas trop vouloir qu'on s'attarde là-dessus.
Est-ce que c'est votre cas aussi ? Est-ce que, au contraire, vous revendiquez l'importance de votre existence politique en tant que femme, en tant que féministe ?
Je pense que les droits des femmes, c'est un peu comme une voiture dans une côte. Vous devez en permanence avoir la main sur le frein à main, sinon elle recule.
Et donc, moi, j'ai aucun problème à dire qu'il faut garder un point d'attention sur la question de l'égalité homme-femme.
Si on ne le fait pas, on peut avoir des revers. Et on voit que dans d'autres pays, en effet, par exemple, le droit à l'avortement est remis en cause.
Donc, je pense qu'il faut rester extrêmement attentif. Maintenant, moi, je n'en fais pas un axe déterminant de ma politique, mais oui, je n'ai pas de problème à dire que je suis,
que je suis féministe et que je suis très fière que, par exemple, tous les organes
de mon parti sont paritaires.
Donc, on prévoit un équilibre, un respect de la parité homme-femme. Donc, c'est quelque chose qui est très très important pour nous et je pense qu'on est d'autant plus crédible quand on met en avant des rôles modèles.
Je vois aussi que dans le secteur du sport, par exemple, on voit de plus en plus de jeunes femmes dans des disciplines dans lesquelles on ne les attendait pas.
Et donc, j'entends souvent au bord des terrains des parents crier aux petites filles : ''Fais attention, tu vas tomber.'' Alors que les petits garçons, on s'attend à ce qu'ils soient plus dynamiques, plus, voilà, plus,
plus risque, plus avec le goût du risque, je dirais.
Donc, il faut essayer de changer notre vocable et changer notre regard aussi sur les petites filles et les petits garçons quand, par exemple, ils se dirigent vers telle ou telle discipline sportive.
Et donc encourager une petite fille qui veut faire de la boxe ou un petit garçon qui veut se lancer dans la gymnastique, par exemple, essayer de dégenrer et d'être au plus proche des aspirations de l'enfant sans prédéterminer son choix.
Et ça vaut aussi pour tout le secteur de l'enseignement, y compris le fait que nous n'avons pas assez de jeunes filles dans les filières STEM, Sciences, Technologie, Ingénierie, Mathématiques.
On a un déficit, oui, et surtout dans les filières numériques, par exemple.
Alors qu'on a un peu plus de un étudiant sur deux, c'est une étudiante, eh bien, on voit que dans certaines filières comme le numérique, il y a seulement une fille pour neuf garçons.
Donc, il faut pouvoir, en mettant en évidence des rôles modèles, par exemple, la présidente de Solvay, on sait que c'est...
Il faut essayer de mettre en évidence des figures féminines fortes qui vont créer un appétit du côté des petites filles et des jeunes filles pour ce type de fonctions.
La question de la faible représentation des femmes dans le secteur numérique, c'était d'ailleurs tout le sujet de l'interview que j'avais faite avec Alexander De Croo, l'épisode un, quand il était ministre de l'Agenda numérique.
C'est comme ça que le podcast a commencé, donc-- sujet qui m'intéresse très fort. Dans le genre rôle modèle, il y a aussi, par exemple, Charline Van Snick,
donc judokate belge bien connue, qui a annoncé mettre fin à sa carrière pour se protéger psychologiquement des abus qu'elle a subis, dont des abus sexuels, semble-t-il.
Il y a aussi l'étude de l'université de Wuppertal en Allemagne qui est sortie en 2020, qui indiquait qu'en Belgique, 80 % des enfants ayant pratiqué un sport ont été victimes d'abus psychologiques ou physiques.
Donc, là aussi, on-- Bon, je n'ai pas été lire l'étude dans le détail, mais on imagine beaucoup de machisme, beaucoup de commentaires un peu militaires, très, très violents chez les garçons et peut-être également chez les filles.
Est-ce que-- Comment est-ce qu'on vient à bout de ça ?
Il faut d'abord rappeler que ça ne concerne pas que le sport ou que l'enseignement supérieur ou que... Ça touche tous les secteurs.
Mais dès qu'il y a une relation asymétrique, en fait. Donc, par exemple,
on a aussi dans les écoles de cinéma des relations asymétriques entre un réalisateur très connu et puis une jeune actrice qui commence ou un athlète, une jeune athlète
et puis un entraîneur très réputé qui peut avoir un ascendant particulier sur l'athlète ou un professeur par rapport à une jeune étudiante ou un jeune étudiant, du reste, par rapport à une professeure, parce que ce n'est pas limité
aux femmes, aux femmes, hein, ce phénomène d'emprise qui peut exister dans toute une série de secteurs.
Alors, comment on fait Moi, j'ai organisé à plusieurs reprises des rencontres entre le milieu des fédérations sportives et des secteurs spécialisés dans la détection des violences liées au genre. Donc, par exemple,
nous avons-- moi, j'étais aussi en charge des maisons de justice. Dans les maisons de justice, nous avons des centres
d'aide aux victimes qui peuvent déconstruire tous les mécanismes qui conduisent à un mécanisme d'emprise, avec aussi un soutien psychologique, mais aussi un soutien qui peut aller jusqu'au dépôt de plainte.
Et on sait que c'est très important d'aller jusqu'au dépôt de plainte. D'abord parce qu'il y a la présomption d'innocence aussi, hein, on peut avoir aussi des phénomènes où il y a,
quelqu'un qui est innocent et il faut pouvoir aussi protéger cette personne.
Mais il faut pouvoir aussi aller jusqu'au dépôt de plainte parce que la victime, à ce moment-là, est reconnue dans son statut de victime.
C'est toute la société qui lui reconnaît ce statut de victime et ça aide la personne à se réparer et à pouvoir reprendre le fil de sa vie.
Donc ça, c'est très important de savoir qu'il existe toute une série de mécanismes et d'institutions, de structures qui peuvent être sollicitées en cas de problème.
Et donc on ne laisse évidemment pas les fédérations sportives seules, comme on ne laisse pas non plus les établissements d'enseignement supérieur seuls, comme on ne laisse pas toute une série d'autres acteurs seuls.
Il faut connaître, et donc ces mécanismes d'échange sont très importants, connaître, par exemple, SOS Viol, qui peut vraiment apporter une aide.
Il y a les centres de prise en charge des victimes de violences sexuelles. Il y a les centres d'aide aux victimes dans les maisons de justice.
Il y en a une ici à Etterbeek, par exemple. Et donc il faut visibiliser toutes ces structures qui existent et les mettre en relation avec des secteurs bien particuliers.
On a organisé, lors de la dernière année de mon mandat, une réunion
spécifique entre les acteurs de l'enseignement supérieur, par exemple les vice-recteurs aux affaires étudiantes et les services des maisons de justice, pour qu'ils puissent mieux connaître les services qui existent
plutôt que de devoir dupliquer dans chacun d'entre eux,
des services qui existent ailleurs.
Et donc l'idée, c'est que au sein de chaque établissement,
il y a une personne relais qui est formée à l'écoute d'une victime et qui est aussi formée en termes de connaissances de toutes les structures qui peuvent être sollicitées pour apporter un soutien.
Mh. Donc là, vous parlez spécifiquement des structures pour les cas des violences sexistes et sexuelles.
Oui, tout à fait. Donc, dans chaque établissement, dans chaque haute école, il y a une personne de référence, comme il doit également y en avoir une dans les fédérations sportives.
Donc l'idée, c'est qu'il y ait une personne qui s'y connaît, hein, pour sortir de ce phénomène un peu de sidération dans lequel on peut se retrouver parce qu'il y a un cas qui émerge
dans un club ou un cas qui émerge dans une haute école et on ne sait pas quoi faire.
Et donc soit il y a la tentation de mettre un couvercle sur la situation, pour préserver la réputation d'un établissement, par exemple, ou alors, il y a aussi la tentation de régler soi-même le problème.
Et ce sont des compétences tout à fait spécifiques, hein. Écouter une victime, la diriger vers le bon service, ça ne s'improvise pas.
Donc il faut une formation, il faut pouvoir diriger cette personne vers le service adéquat qui va offrir un soutien professionnel.
Donc ça, c'est en ce qui concerne alors les victimes de violences sexistes et sexuelles. Un autre sujet, donc, qui a pu diviser, malheureusement, dans le sport, c'est la question des athlètes transgenres,
et particulièrement, donc, les femmes trans.
Vous vous êtes prononcée fermement en faveur de toute mesure qui empêcherait que ces athlètes soient discriminées.
Oui, j'étais inquiète parce que c'était la Fédération internationale d'athlétisme qui se posait la question : comment assurer l'équité par rapport à des athlètes féminines dont certaines pourraient recevoir des hormones.
Et donc, moi, j'ai été très inquiète par rapport au risque, par rapport à la législation internationale de non-discrimination.
Et donc, en effet, j'ai écrit à la Fédération pour attirer son attention sur cette question. On ne peut évidemment pas créer,
de catégories spécifiques, à moins d'évidemment avoir des problèmes au niveau du respect de l'égalité entre les athlètes.
Maintenant, il y a un vrai problème d'équité sportive qu'il faudra trouver à régler, mais je pense qu'on en est vraiment qu'au tout début sur cette question-là.
Il faut à tout prix éviter toute décision qui serait de nature à discriminer des athlètes trans.
Mh. Est-ce que vous pensez qu'un jour, on arrivera à une situation où on cessera de séparer les genres et où on fera des compétitions entre hommes et femmes ?
Bah, ça peut se faire dans toute une série d'initiatives, plutôt d'initiatives sport pour tous. Mais c'est vrai que quand vous avez une compétition, bah évidemment, il y a un différentiel,
voilà, lié aux caractéristiques physiques des hommes et des femmes et donc qui peut évidemment être pénalisant pour les femmes.
Alors, il y a déjà toute une série d'initiatives qui se font, qui mélangent les hommes et les femmes, hein, des disciplines qui s'y prêtent bien et d'autres non.
Donc, évidemment, quand on parle de sport de haut niveau, on voit bien qu'il faut quand même assurer une forme d'équité entre les sportifs eux-mêmes.
Votre mandat a aussi été marqué, donc, puisque on a beaucoup parlé du sport, mais donc vous étiez bien évidemment également ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur.
Votre mandat a été marqué aussi par une série de vagues de dénonciations, de protestations liées au mouvement MeToo, par exemple au cimetière d'Ixelles, mais pas seulement, évidemment.
Beaucoup de manifestations, beaucoup de plaintes, beaucoup de, voilà, de situations de balance ton bar, de viols, de violences sexistes et sexuelles.
Il a été pointé du doigt que les institutions universitaires n'étaient pas forcément responsables, n'étaient pas forcément en situation de sanctionner les éventuelles- Coupable.
Mais il y a des choses différentes dans ce que vous dites hein. Donc d'abord, il y a l'obligation d'avoir une personne qui est formée pour la détection de problèmes liés à des faits de violence sexuelle.
Il y a également, au niveau des établissements, des initiatives qui sont prises. Je pense par exemple T'es OK à l'UCLouvain, donc toute une série d'initiatives de prévention qui sont prises.
Et puis alors, il y a ces journées que j'ai organisées de mise en contact avec des organismes spécialisés dans la prise en charge des violences sexuelles.
Il y a bien sûr deux volets dans ce que vous dites. Donc, il y a l'encouragement des victimes pour qu'elles aillent jusqu'au dépôt de plainte.
Et puis, il peut y avoir des sanctions en interne si, par exemple, s'il y a un problème de violence sexuelle entre des collègues.
Donc, les situations sont extrêmement diverses, mais ce que j'ai voulu à tout prix faire, c'était qu'il y ait dans chaque établissement une personne qui peut vraiment traiter les plaintes parce qu'elles sont extrêmement diverses.
C'est très différent s'il y a un problème de violence sexuelle entre deux étudiants, s'il y a un problème de violence sexuelle supposée entre un membre
de personnel académique et un étudiant, ou si c'est quelque chose qui se passe, par exemple, sur le chemin pour aller à l'université, dans une zone publique.
Donc, ce qui est très important de faire, c'est pouvoir avoir toute une série de dispositifs qui font de la prévention.
Et ça, chaque établissement le fait. Alors bien sûr, on peut toujours aller plus loin. Je sais que, par exemple, nous avons eu durant le mandat, malheureusement, une étudiante qui a été violée à proximité du campus.
On a organisé une rencontre entre la rectrice et la personne en charge des affaires étudiantes, le bourgmestre concerné et les forces de police pour, par exemple, mieux éclairer les alentours de l'université.
Donc, les réponses sont multiples. Ça peut aussi passer par un meilleur éclairage sur un campus. Donc, les réponses ne sont pas unidimensionnelles.
Il faut pouvoir travailler chaque fois en réseau et bien traiter la question avec des personnes, moi, j'insiste hein, formées, parce qu'on ne va pas établir des tribunaux dans chaque établissement.
Ça, ce n'est ni faisable ni, à mon avis, souhaitable. Il faut pouvoir faire appel à une expertise qui existe et chaque fois que la personne concernée soit formée pour faire appel au bon niveau de pouvoir et à la bonne structure.
Donc, vous êtes à ce moment-là opposée à l'idée de faire des sanctions disciplinaires à l'intérieur de l'université ?
Non, bien sûr que non, ça existe. Ça, ça existe déjà. Et donc ça, il y a un règlement d'ordre-
Est-ce que vous auriez évité d'avoir des tribunaux au sein des universités ?
Oui, bien sûr, quand il s'agit de... Moi, j'incite toujours les personnes à aller jusqu'au dépôt de plainte. Et donc la société doit prendre en charge ça, la justice doit prendre en charge ça, donc.
Mais bien sûr, il y a aussi dans le règlement d'ordre intérieur, de façon obligatoire, la lutte contre les violences sexuelles.
Et donc, effectivement, il y a des sanctions qui peuvent être prises aussi.
Si vous avez en tête, par exemple, le fait que c'est un professeur ou une professeure qui aurait commis un fait de harcèlement envers un étudiant ou un étudiant qui harcèle un autre.
Donc, bien sûr, il y a des sanctions qui existent déjà dans les règlements d'ordre intérieur et qui, évidemment, doivent être appliquées.
Et concrètement, est-ce que ça fonctionne bien ? Est-ce que c'est surveillé par la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles ?
L'efficacité de ces structures-là.
Alors, vous devriez peut-être interroger la ministre en charge actuellement-
Ah oui, c'est vrai.
Puisque ça fait sept mois que je, huit mois maintenant que je ne suis plus là. Mais effectivement, on avait commandé une étude pour objectiver la situation.
Et donc, on attend maintenant les recommandations concrètes de l'étude. Je pense que ce qu'il est à tout prix indispensable de faire, c'est évaluer si ce qu'on a mis en place jusqu'ici,
le fait que les violences sexuelles sont dans le règlement d'ordre intérieur, le fait qu'il y a une personne de point de contact dans chaque établissement, est-ce que ça suffit ou pas ?
Sachant qu'il faudra aussi prendre toute une série d'autres mesures dans les autres secteurs de la société. Dans le secteur de la culture, on a beaucoup entendu, par exemple, des jeunes actrices dénoncer le comportement de metteurs en scène qui ont pignon sur rue.
Donc, il faut pouvoir aborder la question des violences sexuelles dans un contexte général qui est beaucoup plus large.
Comme je le disais, dès qu'il y a une relation asymétrique entre deux personnes, peut surgir un phénomène d'emprise.
Et donc, il faut être attentif à cela, mais sans forcément estimer que ce n'est que l'enseignement supérieur qui serait concerné par ça.
Et ça, je pense que c'est... il ne faut pas donner l'impression à des, peut-être, il y a des étudiantes ou futures étudiantes, des élèves qui écoutent votre podcast.
Il ne faut pas les effrayer quant au fait que
ce serait une jungle, l'enseignement supérieur. Il y a toute une série de mécanismes qui existent pour lutter contre les violences sexuelles, de la même façon qu'il y en a aussi dans d'autres secteurs de la société.
On peut toujours les renforcer. Il faut toujours évaluer ce qu'on a mis sur pied, mais je pense qu'il ne faut pas donner à penser qu'il y a une espèce de spécificité à l'enseignement supérieur.
Je voudrais quand même juste citer également ce que nous avons fait en matière de charte des baptêmes, parce qu'on sait qu'il y a-
J'allais en parler.
Ah ben voilà. Je vous en prie, alors je vous laisse poser vos questions.
Mais simplement pour réagir déjà à ce que vous disiez sur le fait que
ce n'est pas spécifique uniquement aux sphères universitaires et aux campus étudiants, qu'est-ce qui explique alors que ce soit en particulier ces voix-là qu'on a pu entendre ces cinq dernières années ?
Je ne pense pas qu'il y a que ces voix-là qu'on a entendues. Moi, je pense qu'on a entendu beaucoup de voix aussi dans le secteur de la culture, dans le secteur du sport, dans le secteur,
de toute une série, dans le secteur même des entreprises.
Donc ce n'est pas spécifique, j'insiste, ce n'est pas spécifique à l'enseignement supérieur.
Il n'y a rien de particulier avec la sphère universitaire. Rien, rien qui distingue-
Comme je le disais, dès que vous avez des relations asymétriques, professeurs, étudiants-
Mais entre étudiants, par exemple.
Bien sûr. Oui, mais comme, enfin, je veux dire, comme le reste de la jeunesse. La jeunesse, c'est pas que les étudiants.
À chaque fois qu'il y a une relation d'emprise, oui, il faut être extrêmement attentif, mais je voudrais-
Donc pas spécifique au secteur universitaire, mais à la jeunesse alors, peut-être ?
Mais comme partout... Non, pas spécifique à la jeunesse non plus. Je pense que
toute personne peut rencontrer un fait de violence sexuelle quand, par exemple, il y a un patron et une jeune employée ou un jeune employé et un patron plus expérimenté.
Partout dans la société, vous avez des relations asymétriques et donc il faut être attentif à ça, mais je ne pense pas que ce soit spécifique à l'enseignement supérieur.
Ceci dit, effectivement, il y a un point d'attention, par exemple, à la consommation d'alcool dans le milieu étudiant, la consommation de drogue aussi, où on a voulu envoyer un signal très clair.
Moi, je sais qu'il y avait une réticence dans le chef de certains responsables d'établissement à se saisir de cette question.
Pourquoi ? Je peux comprendre parce qu'il n'y a pas toujours une relation entre un cercle étudiant et un établissement. Certains cercles fonctionnent de façon complètement indépendante d'un établissement.
Moi, j'ai souhaité mettre en avant une charte des baptêmes qui est également annoncée par les établissements de façon à assurer toute une série de garde-fous.
Par exemple, quand on organise une festivité ou un baptême, il faut à tout prix une personne sobre qui va encadrer le baptême.
On a rappelé : pas de discrimination lors des activités, attention aux violences sexistes. On a une charte que les cercles doivent signer.
Alors, c'est évidemment pas une garantie qu'il ne se passe rien, bien évidemment, mais c'est la première fois qu'on responsabilise les étudiants et qu'on attire leur attention aussi sur les risques d'une consommation abusive d'alcool,
en particulier pour des raisons de santé, bien sûr, parce qu'il y a aussi un risque de dérapage et de mise en danger
de jeunes, mais avant tout pour leur santé.
Ce sont des jeunes qui doivent compter sur leur mémoire et leurs capacités cognitives, leurs capacités intellectuelles. Et on connaît les dégâts de black-out à répétition.
Les black-out, ce moment où on ne se souvient plus de la veille. On connaît les dégâts sur le cerveau, et en termes de fatigue, en termes de difficultés à se concentrer.
Et donc rappeler les conséquences pour un jeune d'un abus de consommation d'alcool, moi, ça me paraissait vraiment important à passer comme message, y compris pour les drogues.
On sait qu'on parle beaucoup de cannabis pour l'instant.
Alors, on sait que la plupart des jeunes qui consomment du cannabis n'auront pas de problèmes de santé mentale, mais quand même, il y a un risque accru lorsqu'on consomme du cannabis et en particulier lorsqu'on le fait avant seize ans,
de développer des problèmes de santé mentale, schizophrénie par exemple.
Et donc, ben, le message, c'est : n'essayez pas, ne prenez pas de risques avec votre santé.
Et consommation abusive d'alcool qui fera aussi très souvent le lit d'un alcoolisme plus tard. Donc c'est effectivement très dangereux et important de sensibiliser à ce niveau-là.
Ce que vous disiez par rapport au fait que les cercles étudiants étaient finalement assez indépendants des structures universitaires elles-mêmes, est-ce qu'il y a eu des efforts pour faire évoluer ça ?
Est-ce qu'il y a eu un effort pour faire répertorier les différents cercles et donner finalement une forme de responsabilité indirecte ?
Oui, on l'a fait. On l'a fait avant tout avec la carotte plutôt qu'avec le bâton. C'est-à-dire, on a fait une journée de sensibilisation où tous les cercles étaient invités.
Donc, ils sont tous venus avec leurs calottes, avec leurs peines, avec... Il y a des cercles régionaux, il y a des cercles qui font des projets particuliers.
Il y a des choses très intéressantes, des activités. Moi, par exemple, je suis baptisée, ben, avec mon cercle, on avait fait une descente de la Leysse pour mieux connaître la province dont je viens.
Donc c'est des activités qui peuvent être très sympas d'inclusion, d'intégration dans un groupe. Aussi des choses qui permettent d'avoir des notes d'un copain, d'être stimulé pendant le blocus.
Donc, il y a des choses positives dans les cercles et ça, je voulais les mettre en évidence aussi. Mais on a fait cette journée d'information pour que les établissements puissent, comme je le disais, utiliser la carotte, c'est-à-dire, par exemple, offrir
à un cercle, ben, une infrastructure pour que le baptême se passe bien.
Ça se passe mieux quand c'est dans un endroit, par exemple, d'une université ou d'une haute école, parce que c'est éclairé, parce qu'il y a le numéro pour appeler le pompier en cas de problème,
parce qu'on les a incités aussi à prévenir les autorités locales, le bourgmestre, quand on fait une activité d'une certaine ampleur, deux cent, trois cent étudiants rassemblés à un même endroit,
eh bien, il faut prendre contact avec les autorités locales au cas où il y a un problème.
Prévenir aussi la police s'il y a, par exemple, beaucoup de personnes qui vont devoir se garer dans tel ou tel endroit. Donc, on a responsabilisé les cercles en ce qui concerne les mesures de sécurité dès qu'on encadre un nombre important de jeunes.
Voilà, on est revenu jusqu'à présent largement sur votre bilan en tant que ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur, ministre des Sports, de la Jeunesse et ainsi de suite.
On ne va pas forcément parler de la promotion de Bruxelles aujourd'hui ou d'Air France-
Et de la jeunesse, Thomas, j'aimais bien
Tout à fait, voilà. Vous êtes actuellement tête de liste au Fédéral pour la circonscription de Bruxelles. Une place absolument avantageuse.
Donc, vous êtes à peu près sûre
d'être élue à la Chambre.
Est-ce qu'actuellement, votre objectif, vos ambitions, vos rêves pour le lendemain du 9 juin, ce serait plutôt de siéger à la Chambre des représentants ou bien est-ce que vous espérez à nouveau opérer en tant que ministre ?
Alors moi, je dois avouer que pour l'instant, je suis concentrée sur la campagne. Donc c'est vrai, je vous fais pas une réponse langue de bois ici.
Je vous dis vraiment au quotidien, je m'attendais pas
à... Je n'étais pas certaine de reprendre la vie politique. J'avais repris mon travail précédent et je suis en effet maintenant, j'ai la certitude que je suis en capacité physique de porter à nouveau un projet politique.
Je suis honorée de tirer la liste fédérale du MR à Bruxelles. J'ai une liste qui associe l'Open VLD, qui associe des représentants de la périphérie.
On a trois ministres sortants, on a trois députés sortants, on a deux échevins, on a des personnes qui représentent toute la société civile, on a une infirmière, on a des entrepreneurs, on a un étudiant, on a une mamie.
Enfin, on a vraiment quelque chose de très équilibré. On a toutes les communes de Bruxelles, le nord, le sud, l'est, ouest.
Et donc je suis très fière de ça. Après, on verra bien le 9 juin dans quelle configuration on se trouve. Moi, j'aimerais, je l'ai pas caché, siéger si je peux en commission santé,
parce que je pense qu'il y a des enjeux absolument déterminants là-dedans.
En bioéthique, par exemple.
On a travaillé. Oui, voilà, ça fait un peu écho à ma formation. Moi, j'ai beaucoup travaillé, comme vous le savez, sur la lutte contre la pénurie, avec un deal sur les numéros INAMI qu'on a fait avec le fédéral, qui va permettre de diplômer
plusieurs milliers de médecins généralistes dans les dix prochaines années.
Donc, je suis très fière de cet accord. Et bien, même si on se rend bien compte qu'il y aura encore des pas à faire, mais là, on est en capacité maintenant de mieux
comptabiliser le nombre d'équivalents temps plein dont on a besoin dans le secteur de la médecine générale, mais aussi dans les spécialisations.
On a mis sur pied une commission de planification de l'offre médicale et on est en capacité maintenant de dire : Tiens, en sortie
de Covid, nous avons besoin de beaucoup plus de gériatres ou de pédopsychiatres, parce qu'il y a des problèmes de santé mentale aussi.
Donc il y a cette commission de planification qui peut calculer au plus près les besoins. Je pense que c'est un élément très très important pour pouvoir,
pour pouvoir lutter contre un phénomène très important qui est la pénurie dans certaines régions du pays.
Donc, moi, je souhaite en effet travailler sur cette question.
Si on fait un petit peu la situation de la campagne actuelle, donc le Mouvement Réformateur est très bien placé dans les sondages, notamment à Bruxelles et également en Wallonie.
Sophie Wilmès sera tête de liste aux Européennes, donc dans toutes les circonscriptions du pays, ce qui fait que forcément, c'est un petit peu une machine à voix, semble-t-il, Sophie Wilmès.
Donc, le Mouvement Réformateur se portera vraisemblablement très bien le 9 juin prochain. Ce n'est pas le seul, puisque le PTB score également très très bien dans les sondages.
Le Vlaams Belang est également en très bonne position. Est-ce qu'on se dirige, selon vous, d'après votre sentiment, sur base, voilà, des sondages actuels, le crédit qu'on leur donne,
vers de nouveau une situation où ce sera très compliqué de faire une formation de gouvernement ?
J'espère que non. Et on est encore en situation de dire aux gens : Attention, ne vous laissez pas berner par les extrêmes, ne votez pas pour les extrêmes.
Parce qu'en effet, quand vous votez pour les extrêmes, vous votez quelque part pour une forme de paralysie. Il faut pouvoir démonter ce qu'il y a derrière les projets des extrêmes.
Ce sont des partis qui ne budgètent en général pas ce qu'ils proposent et qui sont basés avant tout sur un mécanisme de rejet.
Le pathos, ouais.
Oui, ils parlent aux émotions et pas au cerveau. Alors, c'est toujours plus facile de parler aux émotions, mais c'est pas très durable.
Donc, il faut pouvoir parler à la rationalité des électeurs et leur dire qu'on ne peut pas baser un programme sur... Alors, si je parle du Vlaams Belang, c'est la haine de l'étranger qui est responsable de tout.
C'est une espèce de phénomène du bouc émissaire. Ou si je parle du PTB, c'est la haine, la haine du riche, du patron, de l'intelligentsia, de tout qui dépasse un peu, de tout qui veut réussir.
Donc, il y a une espèce de stigmatisation de la réussite à l'extrême gauche qui me fait très peur. On me parle toujours de l'extrême droite dans l'espace francophone et je leur demande toujours : Ben, oui, dites-moi où ?
Parce que ce que je vois surtout, moi, l'éléphant dans la pièce, c'est le PTB. Donc, on l'a vu avec le décret Paysage, donc le PTB siffle et Écolo et PS courent derrière sur la base d'un chiffre faux lancé par-
Surtout eux, ouais.
Voilà. Donc un étudiant sur trois qui sortirait de l'enseignement supérieur, puis ça devient moins de un sur cent. Puis alors, on parlait de mettre le décret à la poubelle.
Puis ensuite, il y avait un moratoire généralisé, puis c'est un moratoire spécifique. Enfin, on voit bien que le sujet s'est complètement dégonflé.
Mais ça veut dire que quand on lance un chiffre faux, comme c'est la technique de l'extrême gauche, c'est-à-dire, ils assènent plusieurs fois un message faux, un mensonge pour que ça devienne une vérité.
C'est une technique de com', donc imposer plusieurs fois, répéter plusieurs fois un mensonge pour que ça devienne une vérité.
Malheureusement, certains partis de gauche y sont sensibles et remettent complètement à plat une réforme qu'ils ont votée il y a trois ans, donc sur la base d'un chiffre faux.
Donc, je pense que là, on voit bien que c'est une forme d'instrumentalisation en pré-blocus de l'inquiétude d'étudiants.
On les traite un peu comme du vulgaire gibier électoral et on leur vend au passage du rêve. On leur fait croire que si on leur donne, alors qu'ils ont déjà échoué
quatre, cinq, six, sept fois, si on leur donne une possibilité supplémentaire d'échouer, ils vont y arriver.
Moi, je pense plutôt qu'il faut dire à ces étudiants : Réorientez-vous pour terminer avec un diplôme de l'enseignement supérieur.
Ça, c'est un message responsable et qui est vraiment au service des étudiants. Donc c'est vraiment leur dire : Identifiez plus rapidement si vous êtes bien sur une trajectoire de réussite.
Si vous n'êtes pas sur une trajectoire de réussite, il existe des aides à la réussite. Elles ont été considérablement augmentées.
Et puis, si vraiment ça ne va pas, il y a un bonus réorientation. Parce qu'on sait que statistiquement, un étudiant qui est en difficulté, il a plus de chances de terminer diplômé s'il change de cursus que s'il persévère dans le même cursus.
Et donc c'est vraiment cette idée de dire à un étudiant qui... et par exemple, je prends journalisme parce que vous êtes journaliste, journaliste dans une université, il ne s'en sort pas au bout de la première année.
Il voit bien que ça n'a pas été pour les examens de janvier, ça n'a pas été pour les examens de juin. Eh bien, on lui dit : mais réessaie, par exemple, journalisme en haute école, il peut choisir ça.
On remet à zéro sa finançabilité et il a à nouveau deux années pour réussir ses soixante crédits. Eh bien, cet étudiant-là a beaucoup plus de chances de sortir diplômé.
Et c'est ça qu'on veut faire, c'est faire diminuer le nombre d'étudiants qui se retrouvent chaque année non finançables, parce qu'il y a chaque année entre dix et quinze pour cent d'étudiants qui se découvrent non finançables.
Et on veut augmenter le nombre d'étudiants diplômés et au passage aussi lutter contre l'allongement des études parce que c'est cet allongement-là qui précarise les étudiants, hein. Quand la FEF dit
: il y a une énorme précarité étudiante, la FEF a raison. Mais évidemment, si vous faites dix, douze années à la place de cinq années d'études, à un moment donné, les parents se désolidarisent, ne comprennent plus où leur enfant en est.
Ils ne savent plus si leur enfant est bien sur une trajectoire de réussite. Ils se désolidarisent de l'enfant qui doit commencer à jobber.
Et là, c'est un cercle vicieux parce que plus on jobbe, moins on réussit. Et donc on a comme ça un très grand nombre
d'étudiants qui se retrouvent sur une trajectoire d'échec depuis plusieurs années alors qu'ils ont financé un grand nombre d'années d'études.
Et c'est ça qu'on voulait réduire en mettant plus de cadres, plus de balises, parce qu'on sait que ce sont les étudiants les plus précaires qui souffrent de l'absence de balises claires, hein.
Ceux qui n'ont pas des parents qui ont fait l'université pour leur expliquer les conséquences d'un report de crédit d'une année à l'autre, eh bien ce sont ces étudiants-là qu'on retrouve sur une trajectoire d'échec.
Et on avait des chiffres d'ailleurs, hein, le nombre d'étudiants boursiers qui réussissaient leur bachelier dans les temps était passé de dix-neuf pour cent à quatorze pour cent.
Et donc c'est ça qu'on a essayé de faire en mettant des balises plus claires pour que les étudiants se situent bien et identifient plus rapidement un échec.
Un échec, c'est pas la fin du monde, on a le droit de rater, on a le droit de s'être mal orienté, mais à un moment donné, il faut pouvoir constater un échec, aller chercher des aides à la réussite et si vraiment
on n'y arrive pas, pouvoir se réorienter pour terminer avec ce fameux sésame qui est ce titre de l'enseignement supérieur qui certifie des compétences parce qu'on vit dans une société du papier,
on a besoin de ce fameux papier pour s'insérer professionnellement.
Et au passage, il faut aussi rappeler que ce décret paysage, il vise aussi à ramener la qualité du diplôme, hein, contre une forme de réussite automatique ou de réussite à l'usure.
Il est important de rappeler qu'il faut aussi réussir dans un certain temps donné. Et si ça ne fonctionne pas, il y a plein d'autres formations qui sont extrêmement intéressantes, extrêmement bien rémunérées aussi, hein,
et auxquelles l'étudiant n'a peut-être pas spontanément pensé.
Et donc des filières, par exemple dans le secteur du numérique, qui sont très bien rémunérées. Et souvent, les étudiants n'y pensent pas.
Et donc toutes les filières STEM, par exemple, sont souvent sous-représentées dans le choix des étudiants, dans leur premier choix en tout cas.
Et puis quand il y a une aide à la réorientation qui est saisie, ça peut être quelque chose qui est extrêmement épanouissant.
Le plus important pour nous, c'est, en tout cas pour moi, c'est que l'étudiant ne perde à aucun moment le goût de l'apprentissage.
Et quand on échoue plusieurs fois et qu'à aucun moment, il n'y a de moment de stop, on n'est pas incité à se réorienter.
Et donc il y a cette... Je pense qu'il y a une forme de vente de rêves aux étudiants. Et à un moment donné, il faut leur dire : réorientez-vous parce que vous n'êtes pas sur une trajectoire de réussite.
Et ce n'est pas la fin du monde parce qu'il y a énormément de formations qui existent, y compris dans les établissements,
dans les hautes écoles, parce qu'on parle toujours des universités, mais la moitié de l'enseignement supérieur, ce sont des hautes écoles qui font un travail exceptionnel.
Il y a également les établissements d'enseignement de promotion sociale qui ont des petites pépites de formation et on a tendance à tout focaliser sur l'université.
Est-ce que c'est pas spécifiquement belge, cette notion de tout focaliser sur l'université et puis mettre un petit peu les hautes écoles un petit peu sur le côté, entre parenthèses ?
Mais je pense qu'il y a quelque chose de fantastique dans notre système et dont moi, je suis très fière et que je n'ai pas voulu changer, c'est le fait que n'importe quel élève qui sort de n'importe quelle
de n'importe quelle école a le droit d'essayer l'université.
Et ça, c'est très précieux. Et il faut qu'il puisse conserver ce droit. Mais si ça ne fonctionne pas, il faut aussi pouvoir constater un échec et aider cet étudiant ou cet élève à se réorienter et ne pas le laisser pendant des années,
sur une trajectoire qui n'est pas une trajectoire de réussite.
Et là, c'est vrai qu'il faut pouvoir offrir
autre chose à l'étudiant. Donc moi, je suis très fière que chacun puisse tenter l'université, même en sortant d'une filière technique ou professionnelle, mais il faut aussi rappeler qu'il y a des prérequis.
Et donc si on n'a pas les prérequis, il faut inciter l'étudiant, par exemple, à faire une préparation. Et il n'est pas question de baisser le niveau de l'enseignement supérieur.
C'est à l'étudiant à franchir la marche qui est parfois en effet très élevée, la marche entre l'enseignement obligatoire et l'enseignement supérieur.
C'est pour ça qu'on a mis sur pied, par exemple, un
un test, un parcours d'orientation pour que l'étudiant,
quand il sort de sa sixième secondaire, puisse évaluer s'il a bien les prérequis et s'il ne les a pas, de pouvoir suivre toute une série de cours pour pouvoir franchir cette fameuse marche.
Et donc, si je ne me trompe pas, actuellement, donc le décret paysage ou en tout cas le report d'un an voté par PS, Ecolo et PTB a été envoyé face au Conseil d'État.
Oui, parce qu'il n'y a pas eu d'avis du Conseil d'État, ce qui est quand même assez étonnant. Il y a eu ni avis du Conseil d'État ni audition des acteurs de l'enseignement supérieur.
Nous avions proposé qu'ils soient entendus parce qu'ils sont contre ce qu'ont proposé PS et Ecolo, radicalement contre, parce qu'ils pensent qu'à nouveau, on leurre les étudiants en leur faisant croire qu'avec encore une année, ça va aller.
À un moment donné, il faut... Ce n'est pas parce qu'ils vont se faire rattraper par le nouveau décret.
Ils se faisaient déjà rattraper.
Dans l'ancien système, il y avait déjà des règles de la finançabilité. Et donc un étudiant qui reportait quinze crédits, puis encore quinze crédits, en troisième année,
il se retrouvait avec un sac à dos de crédits non validés trop lourds à porter et c'était la porte de l'enseignement supérieur qui se refermait.
Et donc ces étudiants, d'abord, on dit : on les a sauvés, je ne sais pas de quoi. Les professeurs sont évidemment très furieux quand ils entendent qu'ils auraient été sauvés de...
Comme si les professeurs étaient dépossédés de leur capacité à amener à la réussite les étudiants. Donc, je pense que le personnel académique est très très mécontent.
Il y a aussi une absence de prise en compte du budget. Et donc, on a refinancé l'enseignement supérieur avec quatre-vingt millions d'euros en plus chaque année.
Ça, c'était la promesse de notre gouvernement. Je l'ai fait. On avait prévu cinquante millions, on a pu aller jusqu'à quatre-vingt millions.
Eh bien, ce qu'on voit là, c'est qu'avec cette mesure décidée par PS et Ecolo sous pression du PTB et avec l'aide du PTB, puisque le PTB l'a voté, eh bien, on voit qu'on va définancer de façon structurelle les établissements.
C'est la raison pour laquelle ils sont furieux.
Et donc actuellement, donc, face au Conseil d'État, quel est votre sentiment par rapport à ça ? Vous espérez que le Conseil d'État va trancher en faveur du-
Mais moi, je n'espère pas. J'ai peur pour nos étudiants. Je... Bien sûr, on est en campagne électorale, mais il y a quelque chose, enfin, je veux dire, il y a quand même quelque chose d'autre que le neuf juin.
Il y a une session d'examen.
Il n'y a pas que la campagne électorale.
Et donc on est en train ici de jouer avec l'avenir des étudiants en leur faisant croire qu'on est les grands sauveurs des étudiants, alors qu'en fait, moi, ce qui
me, ce qui m'inquiète, ce qui m'angoisse, ce sont tous ces étudiants qui ne sont pas sur une trajectoire de réussite et qui vont continuer. Et donc-
Étant donné la situation, plus que-
Sans pouvoir constater un échec et sans non plus pouvoir se mettre dans une... Ils ont besoin de calme, ils ont besoin de concentration.
Donc moi, je propose de ne pas trop parler de ce qui va se passer sur le plan juridique, parce que ce que je veux passer comme message aux étudiants, c'est le même message que celui que porte
Françoise Bertieaux, qui est la ministre en charge de l'enseignement supérieur.
C'est : vous avez besoin de calme, vous avez besoin de concentration. Allez-y, passez vos examens. Il y a encore deux sessions.
Mais donc, en raison de l'ambiguïté qui plane et les incertitudes, effectivement, on aurait plutôt tendance à conseiller aux étudiants de ne pas prendre de risques et de-
Mais il faut toujours passer comme message aux étudiants de se mettre sur une trajectoire de réussite. Je ne sais pas quel ministre de l'enseignement supérieur, actuel ou passé, oserait dire à un étudiant qu'à ce moment de l'année,
on est au mois de mai, ils doivent se concentrer sur leurs examens.
C'est... Ils doivent pouvoir se mettre sur une trajectoire de réussite. Et donc ce qu'on a fait, c'est quelque part créer beaucoup de chaos, d'incompréhension, y compris du côté du personnel administratif.
Et donc, je sais que le message qu'a passé la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur, moi, je le trouve excellent, à savoir concentrez-vous sur vos examens et mettez tout en place pour vous trouver sur une trajectoire de réussite.
Je pense que c'est le seul conseil responsable à leur passer.
Pour revenir donc à la campagne électorale, puisqu'on a fait un fameux détour par le décret paysage, le Mouvement Réformateur, donc, dans sa communication,
met régulièrement en avant la notion des cinquante nuances de gauche auxquelles il est opposé.
Dans la situation actuelle, vu les sondages actuels, vu la montée des extrêmes, etc., en fait, on a du mal à imaginer comment le MR pourrait être partenaire d'autre chose que ces cinquante nuances de gauche.
Mais je vais reprendre le dossier dont on vient de discuter. Ce qu'on a vu, c'est qu'effectivement, il y a très peu de...
Il y a un clivage très net, hein, sur le dossier du décret paysage. Le PTB a mis la pression sur PS et Ecolo, qui ont suivi.
On a des inquiétudes quant au fait qu'un Olivier existerait, qui associe Les Engagés. Donc voilà, moi, je crains aussi très fort un axe PS-NVA, où on pourrait avoir un refinancement
demandé par le PS pour faire des cadeaux électoraux en échange de davantage de compétences qui seraient données pour satisfaire l'appétit nationaliste,
de la NVA.
Donc moi, je suis très très inquiète et je pense qu'en effet, il est très important d'essayer de travailler sur un axe de centre-droit.
C'est ce que fait mon président qui a fait cette interview dont vous avez entendu parler avec Sami Mahdi, puisqu'on partage toute une série de choses en commun.
Donc, je pense qu'effectivement, ce qu'a montré le décret paysage, c'est qu'il y avait très peu de personnes qui étaient du côté de la défense de la qualité des diplômes, la défense de l'effort, du mérite, de...
Oui, le fait qu'un diplôme doit valoir quelque chose.
Est-ce que c'est comme ça que vous interprétez la présence, dans les circonscriptions wallonnes, de la NVA sur les listes ?
C'est pour affaiblir le Mouvement Réformateur en faveur du Parti socialiste ? C'est ça, votre interprétation ?
Alors, je ne sais pas s'il y a une volonté délibérée de le faire, mais je pense qu'en effet, ça risque d'affaiblir le Mouvement Réformateur au bénéfice finalement d'un axe NVA-PS que,
qui me fait très très peur parce que je pense qu'il y a un risque pour notre pays.
Donc, on est très très attachés, nous, à plutôt aller dans l'autre sens pour une série de compétences. Par exemple, la médecine préventive, on pense qu'il faut la refédéraliser.
On voit bien qu'il y a des incohérences à ce que le fédéral soit en charge du financement et en même temps, les régions font de la médecine préventive, donc il n'y a pas d'incitant réel à performer en termes de médecine préventive.
Et on fait moins bien que les autres à ce sujet. On investit moins aussi dans la médecine préventive. Donc, je pense qu'il y aurait vraiment un intérêt, par exemple, à refédéraliser la médecine préventive.
Il y avait déjà eu une tentative, donc c'était pendant l'été 2020, si je ne dis pas de bêtises, pour faire une coalition, donc PS-NVA, ça n'avait pas abouti, semble-t-il.
Il y avait des décalages trop importants, notamment la question des exigences, de faire en sorte que le vingt et un juillet ne soit plus un jour férié, etc.
Ce genre de revendications nationalistes. Donc, encore une fois, si on se base sur les sondages récents, la NVA est affaiblie.
Ouais, on aurait du mal à imaginer comment ça pourrait mieux marcher cette fois-ci que la fois précédente. Vous pensez qu'il y a eu un changement de stratégie de leur part ?
Je ne suis pas dans la tête de Bardeau et Vert, c'est difficile à dire. J'imagine bien qu'il y a, on sent quand même une certaine fébrilité pour l'instant.
Alors c'est très difficile pour l'instant de faire des pronostics en campagne électorale. Ce que je peux vous dire, c'est que nous, on a dit qu'on ne ferait pas de coalition avec les extrêmes.
Donc ça, c'est très clair et qu'on privilégie un axe de centre-droit pour essayer de pouvoir réaliser le maximum de notre programme.
On pense qu'il est impératif de pouvoir
libérer, soulager la pression fiscale qui pèse sur les épaules des entrepreneurs et également revaloriser les bas salaires pour qu'il y ait un différentiel par rapport aux allocations de chômage et pouvoir activer la grande partie de la population.
On a huit cent mille personnes inactives en Belgique. Si on en active ne fût-ce que deux cent mille, ça rapporte cinq virgule cinq milliards d'euros à l'État.
Donc, on voit qu'il y a un cercle vertueux à créer et on est très inquiet qu'on ne puisse pas mettre sur pied ces réformes.
On en a besoin. Vous savez que l'Union européenne va nous imposer des règles budgétaires un peu plus strictes puisque après la période
Covid, la guerre en Ukraine, où il y avait eu un peu de souplesse accordée, maintenant, il y a un point d'attention à ce qu'on puisse avoir des trajectoires budgétaires plus responsables.
Et donc il va falloir en effet faire des efforts et on ne peut pas se permettre d'avoir une période comme on l'a eu dans le passé avec une formation de gouvernement qui prend des mois et des mois.
Nous ne sommes pas dans une situation budgétaire qui nous autorise à faire ça. Quand on voit en particulier la situation de la région bruxelloise, la note de la région bruxelloise a été dégradée par l'agence de notation Standard & Poor's.
On voit bien qu'on ne peut plus se permettre d'attendre, en particulier au niveau de la région bruxelloise, qui a laissé filer le déficit de façon extrêmement angoissante.
Vous privilégiez donc l'option d'une coalition de centre-droit, donc a priori avec l'Open VLD. Open VLD qui ne se porte vraiment plus très bien du tout.
On est à peine autour des cinq pour cent, ce qui...
Non, il y a une remontée quand même dans le dernier sondage,
je pense dix pour cent. Donc, on est quand même... Ils sont dans une stratégie, en tout cas, je ne sais pas si on peut aller jusqu'à dire une stratégie d'ascension, mais en tout cas, ça va nettement mieux.
Ils sont en ordre de marche. Ça s'est très bien passé, la désignation des listes. Moi, je suis très fière d'avoir sur ma liste en quatrième position Alexia Bertrand, qui est secrétaire d'État au budget, avec laquelle
il est très très agréable de travailler.
Nous avons les mêmes... Qui est Open VLD. Et donc, nous avons également sur la liste Frédéric De Gucht et Joris Steelen.
Donc, il y a trois représentants Open VLD sur la liste parce qu'on partage une vision commune sur ce qu'il faut pour Bruxelles.
On est convaincus qu'il faut plus de Bleus à Bruxelles parce qu'on a un problème de pauvreté. Il y a quand même un Bruxellois sur trois qui n'a pas accès à un médecin généraliste pour des raisons financières.
On a un problème, j'espère qu'on aura l'occasion d'en parler parce que c'est le sujet numéro un de la campagne, c'est l'insécurité urbaine liée au narcobanditisme.
Et on voit bien que le PS a une réponse qui est complètement floue, avec un ministre président qui dit qu'il n'y a pas de zone de non-droit à Bruxelles, avec un
candidat sur la liste Europe qui parle de dépénaliser, pas le cannabis, la cocaïne.
Donc, on voit qu'il y a une réponse extrêmement floue du partenaire, de l'ancien partenaire PS. Donc nous, on pense qu'en effet, il faut avoir davantage de Bleu pour appréhender cette situation.
Nous, on veut mettre sur pied un grand plan de lutte contre l'insécurité urbaine. Ce qu'on voit, c'est qu'en permanence, pour l'instant, avec la majorité bruxelloise, il y a un renvoi de l'ascenseur.
Alors une fois, ils disent que ce n'est pas eux, c'est le fédéral. Le fédéral dit que c'est la région. La région dit que c'est les communes.
Donc nous, ce qu'on appelle de nos vœux, c'est la fin de ce ping-pong de responsabilité, un grand plan national de lutte contre l'insécurité urbaine.
On s'attaque bien sûr à la tête, les narcotrafiquants. Il faut travailler sur l'arrivée
de drogue via les ports. Et on avait,
vous le savez, demandé qu'on puisse envoyer l'armée
pour soulager la police et pour qu'elle puisse être déchargée d'une série de missions bien précises, bien spécifiques pendant un certain temps pour pouvoir déployer davantage de moyens pour lutter contre le narcobanditisme.
Ça a été refusé par le PS qui a par ailleurs envoyé la police, en tout cas l'armée,
faire un petit peu quelques petites missions dans le cadre des JO à Paris, mais pas pour aider Bruxelles, par exemple, qui est complètement gangrenée par le narcobanditisme.
Donc, il faut également travailler sur la demande, parce que s'il y a une telle offre, c'est aussi parce qu'il y a une demande.
Et donc rappeler aux consommateurs que oui, quand ils consomment de la drogue, ils font partie d'un système qui alimente des organisations criminelles.
Ils ne s'en sont pas toujours conscients. Je pense qu'il faut rappeler la règle un peu, qui est en particulier pour les jeunes, c'est mieux de ne pas consommer.
Et donc ça, avoir un message tout à fait clair par rapport à la consommation de drogue, en particulier à destination des jeunes, ça me semble capital.
On va donc revenir sur la question de l'insécurité à Bruxelles par rapport à la drogue, mais pas seulement. Juste pour revenir sur la question du vote de protestation, la montée des extrêmes.
Est-ce que vous faites l'interprétation de ce vote de protestation comme finalement une critique du bilan de la Vivaldi ?
Est-ce que les partis traditionnels ont une forme d'échec à leur actif qui fait que ça motive un vote de protestation ?
D'abord, il faut rappeler aux personnes qu'elles ont encore les moyens, puisqu'on n'a pas encore voté, de ne pas voter pour les extrêmes.
Parce qu'en effet, quand on vote pour les extrêmes, il faut faire une coalition de tous les autres. Et c'est vrai que la Vivaldi, c'est sept partis politiques.
Et donc forcément, ça donne des infléchissements politiques qui sont moins clairs.
Mais si on interprète ce vote comme un vote ras-le-bol, je pense qu'ils ne seront pas forcément dérangés par cette...
Il faut leur rappeler que quand on... Quand on n'est pas autour de la table, on est souvent sur le menu. Et donc il ne faut pas laisser à quelqu'un d'autre le choix de décider à sa place.
Et donc il faut aller voter et il faut se renseigner sur les programmes des partis et demander à chaque fois la budgétisation des promesses qui sont faites par les partis extrêmes.
Et il faut aussi éviter de donner des arguments. Et ça, c'est ce qu'on a essayé de faire aux nationalistes flamands, par exemple, en essayant d'avoir les mêmes taux d'activation des personnes sans emploi que chez eux.
Quand je vois par exemple qu'à Bruxelles, on a un taux de jeunes qui ne sont ni à l'emploi ni en formation qui est de neuf virgule un pour cent alors qu'en Flandre, c'est cinq pour cent, on voit bien qu'il y a quelque chose à faire en termes de
de formation des jeunes, hein.
Il y en a trop qui passent sous le radar de l'école ou de la formation. Donc, probablement qu'il y a quelque chose qu'on peut mieux faire et peut-être aussi qu'on doit cesser de
en tout cas donner des arguments à ceux qui disent qu'on fait moins bien dans la sphère francophone.
Mh. Donc une forme de reconnaissance de on aurait pu faire mieux. La Vivaldi a été marquée au fédéral, donc, par beaucoup de conflits en interne, hein.
On caractérise la participation du Mouvement Réformateur comme étant une participosition, notamment par la voix du président, Georges-Louis Bouchez.
On se souvient de la formation de gouvernement qui a eu lieu, donc, en 2020, où Georges-Louis Bouchez a dû être exclu et on a dû appeler Sophie Wilmès pour venir négocier cette-
Oui, alors, je voudrais tout de suite rectifier. Moi, il ne me semble pas anormal qu'un président de parti marque une ligne, marque une différence.
C'est son rôle. Je veux rappeler aussi qu'il a défendu plusieurs acquis de la Vivaldi. Donc, on a mentionné bien sûr la prolongation des réacteurs.
On a pu apporter un soutien tout à fait clair à l'Ukraine dans notre politique étrangère. On a également une position équilibrée dans le conflit israélo-palestinien.
On a évité une réforme fiscale qui aurait pu peser très lourdement sur les épaules des entrepreneurs et des ménages, puisqu'il y avait une taxe sur des produits de consommation courante qu'on a pu éviter.
Il y a toute une série de choses qu'on a soutenues, mais c'est vrai que c'est moins lisible avec cette partie autour de la table.
Ça, c'est une évidence et c'est pour ça qu'on espère que l'électeur va nous donner un signal le plus clair possible, parce que nous souhaitons en effet monter dans des majorités, en particulier à Bruxelles, où on pense que
il est déterminant de pouvoir changer le cap.
On voit la frustration des gens par rapport à la mobilité, ça, c'est très clair, par rapport à la sécurité. Quand vous interrogez les gens dans la rue, les thèmes qui reviennent le plus souvent, c'est ça, hein, c'est
des problèmes de mobilité avec une PME sur deux qui dit qu'elle va quitter Bruxelles parce qu'elle n'arrive plus à accéder dans le centre.
Également des problèmes de sécurité, des problèmes de saleté dans la ville et puis des problèmes de formation.
Alors qu'on a une population très jeune, il y a vraiment trop de jeunes qui passent sous le radar de l'école.
Pour revenir à cette notion de parti d'opposition, puisque donc c'est la plainte de vos partenaires de gouvernement-
Oui, mais je m'inscris en faux. Je pense que c'est tout à fait normal qu'un président de parti puisse marquer un cap.
Quand c'est un autre président de parti qui le fait-
C'est leur sentiment, c'est le constat qu'ils dressent. Est-ce que, à ce moment-là, on ne court pas le risque qu'au lendemain du 9 juin, les éventuels partenaires de gouvernement préfèrent
d'autres partis, d'autres partis libéraux, par exemple, comme Les Engagés ou-
Je ne vais pas répondre à votre question puisque moi, je ne suis pas d'accord avec le constat qui est posé. Donc, je pense qu'il est tout à fait normal qu'un président de parti indique une ligne.
Et il a été beaucoup reproché, par exemple, à Georges-Louis Bouchez d'aller débattre avec Tom Van Grieken. Hein, il a mis-
Avec l'extrême droite.
Oui, il a démonté avec un talent que je n'ai rencontré nulle part ailleurs les arguments du Vlaams Belang.
Alors, moi, j'attends encore que quelqu'un fasse aussi bien que lui pour inciter les gens à ne pas voter pour les extrêmes.
Plutôt que suivre le PTB dès qu'il siffle, j'attends des responsables politiques des autres partis qu'ils fassent aussi bien que mon président pour les décourager de voter pour les extrêmes.
Ça, c'est quelque chose qui serait déterminant et qui est de nature à éviter que les gens votent pour les extrêmes.
Donc, par exemple, je prends un exemple au hasard, mais déclarer dans les médias que Thomas Dermine, je ne sais pas ce qu'il fout, c'est simplement marquer une ligne et c'est une façon élégante de faire de la politique.
Je pense que c'est en tout cas un appel au ministre, ministre en charge de l'emploi, pour qu'il puisse également faire son travail.
Je ne me serais pas exprimée de cette façon-là, c'est clair, mais je pense qu'il y a eu en tout cas une déception par rapport aux réformes qui auraient pu être portées pour activer davantage de personnes.
Je le disais, huit cent mille personnes-
Thomas Dermine, secrétaire d'État à la Relance.
Ah, vous avez parlé de Thomas Dermine.
Thomas Dermine, oui.
Oui, je pensais que vous parliez de monsieur Dermagne.
Non, non, Thomas Dermine.
Oui. Je pense que ça, ça concernait monsieur Dermagne, sauf erreur de ma part.
Ah, je suis à peu près sûr que c'est Thomas Dermine.
Bon, très bien. Dans tous les cas, ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'il ne m'apparaît pas anormal qu'un président de parti signale un cap et indique une frustration par rapport à un programme qui a été mis en œuvre par quelqu'un d'autre.
Si vous prenez ce qui s'est passé sur le décret Paysage, nous avions voté une réforme il y a trois ans et j'ai entendu,
mon ancienne collègue Caroline Désir dénoncer quelque chose, à Jeudi en prime, qu'elle avait pourtant signé des deux mains.
Donc, si vous me demandez s'il n'y a pas un petit peu de posture partisane dans le chef d'autres responsables politiques, je vous dis : oui, c'est tout à fait clair.
Mh, mh, mh. Le CDH se portait très mal en 2019 lors des dernières élections. Une remontée qui est en cours. Vous évoquiez le fait que ce serait mieux de ne pas avoir sept partis autour de la table cette fois-ci.
Et en même temps, vous reconnaissez que la montée des extrêmes fait que ça va être très compliqué de ne pas avoir sept partis autour de la table.
Cette partie qui, donc, vous ne partagez pas leur constat, mais leur constat est là malgré tout, qu'ils n'ont pas apprécié de travailler avec le Mouvement Réformateur ?
Oui, mais donc si toutes vos questions sont destinées à dire que nous sommes isolés, je veux juste rappeler que nous avons, nous avons ces-
Les deux dernières questions.
Ben oui, c'est un peu toujours la même, vous répétez plusieurs fois la même chose. Donc, je m'inscris en faux. Je veux rappeler que nous avons fait ce constat d'une certaine cohérence de ligne avec le CD&V.
On a vu également que les Engagés se sont positionnés pour défendre le décret Paysage version Glatigny. Donc, je pense que nous ne sommes pas isolés.
Alors, certains ont peut-être un intérêt à nous présenter comme isolés, mais je ne pense pas que ce soit le cas.
Très bien. Repassons maintenant alors à la Région bruxelloise et la question de l'insécurité. Donc on a pu parler, hein, de la question de la consommation de drogue et des violences qui sont liées à cela.
Il y a également, par exemple, la situation de la gare du Midi, où j'ai l'occasion, voilà, j'ai encore l'occasion de passer par là pour vous rejoindre aujourd'hui.
Comment est-ce que vous expliquez le fait que la Région bruxelloise ait pu gérer cette situation-là aussi mal ?
Puisqu'il y a eu une communication dans la presse il y a quelques mois pour dénoncer la situation.
Effectivement, on a pu voir une intervention policière, on a pu voir que ça a été un, la zone a été un petit peu nettoyée, pour ainsi dire, si je puis me permettre.
Mais très rapidement, la situation est revenue dans son état précédent. Qu'est-ce qui explique ? Qu'est-ce que la Région bruxelloise aurait pu faire mieux ?
Et qu'est-ce qui explique que ça a été aussi mal géré ? Qu'est-ce qui est si compliqué à la gare du Midi, finalement ?
Mais il y a peut-être une forme d'angélisme d'abord. Il faut d'abord constater les faits et la gravité de la situation. Ça, c'est la première chose.
Après, il faut mettre en place un véritable plan où on arrête de se renvoyer les responsabilités à gauche et à droite.
Mh. Vous le dites bien.
Et donc vraiment, oui, mais c'est capital, ça commence par ça. On met tout le monde autour de la table et on voit comment répondre en urgence aux problèmes.
On a toute une série de problèmes, hein, en particulier le fait que la police est mobilisée très fortement pour des questions de narcobanditisme.
Si je prends l'exemple, par exemple, de la Hollande, où on a dépénalisé le cannabis, eh ben, on voit que 80 % des forces policières sont occupées par le narcobanditisme.
Donc là, j'attire l'attention sur la fausse solution qui serait la fausse bonne idée, qui serait la dépénalisation du cannabis.
Je pense qu'il faut rappeler la règle, c'est qu'on ne consomme pas, hein. Donc c'est vraiment ça qui est important.
Donc c'est qu'à tous les niveaux, on puisse, au niveau aussi bien de la demande que de l'offre, agir. Et on se rend compte aussi qu'au niveau des forces de police, il y a toute une série de nouveaux profils qui sont demandés.
Par exemple, un besoin en médecin légiste, un besoin d'expert balistique suite aux fusillades. Et donc il faudra pouvoir rencontrer ces problèmes.
Il y a un problème de recrutement. Il y a un problème aussi qui a été soulevé par Inne Van Wymersch, qui explique qu'il va falloir aussi pouvoir revoir nos règles en matière de protection de la vie privée, parce que,
les narcotrafiquants ont toujours une longueur d'avance en termes de-
Chiffrement.
Voilà. Et donc c'est important de pouvoir également revoir tout notre arsenal législatif pour être à la hauteur, apporter une réponse qui soit véritablement à la hauteur.
Et ça passe aussi, nous, on n'a pas de tabou pour parler du financement de nos forces régaliennes.
On sait que dans les dépenses de l'État, à ces 200 milliards d'euros, il y a seulement 2,7 % pour ce qu'on appelle les forces régaliennes, donc police et justice.
Est-ce qu'il faut revoir à la hausse les budgets ? En tout cas, c'est pas un tabou pour nous, en particulier parce qu'il s'agira aussi de renforcer le traitement judiciaire, hein.
Donc, on sait que le parquet de Bruxelles est en grande souffrance. Donc, il faudra agir sur toute une série de choses. Et c'est la raison pour laquelle, moi, je suis convaincue que la seule solution, c'est un plan
national, ça veut pas dire fédéral, mais un plan national
avec tous les niveaux de pouvoir concernés, y compris bien sûr au premier chef, les bourgmestres, parce qu'ils ont une responsabilité également en termes de lutte contre l'insécurité.
Mais donc c'est vrai que la réponse qui a été fournie est particulièrement floue. Moi, j'ai entendu dire qu'il y avait pas de zone de non-droit à Bruxelles.
Je me suis promenée récemment dans un quartier chaud, je vais pas le nommer pour ne pas le stigmatiser, mais je ne me suis pas sentie en sécurité.
Donc c'est d'abord un constat de la gravité de la situation qu'il est impératif de poser.
Mh. Donc, je partage effectivement le constat du sous-financement de la justice et éventuellement de l'exécutif, de la police.
On approche, suite au vote qui a été fait au niveau européen, d'une période d'austérité. Vous évoquez le fait de-
Je sais pas s'il faut parler d'austérité. C'est à nouveau un terme très connoté. Pardon, mais on parle de rigueur. Voilà, rigueur, ben, c'est très différent.
Je pense que le retour à une forme d'équilibre, c'est indispensable simplement pour tout qui a un enfant, hein, parce que c'est un cadeau empoisonné qu'on lui laisse de laisser filer les-
Et donc cette rigueur, voilà, pour empêcher donc l'endettement notamment et le maintien d'un PIB à un taux de croissance important,
fait que donc augmenter les budgets de, voilà, pour la justice et pour la police,
où est-ce que vous allez trouver cet argent si ce n'est pas par l'endettement ?
Parce que, et que vous êtes par ailleurs opposée aux taxes.
Oui, on ne veut pas de taxes. On pense qu'on est déjà le pays le plus taxé au monde et on est au niveau du travail et on est dans le top trois de la taxation patrimoine.
Je pense qu'on peut très bien trouver de la souplesse en réduisant certaines dépenses qui ne sont pas efficaces.
Et donc ce sera sur ça qu'il faudra agir.
À quoi pensez-vous ?
Ben par exemple, je mentionnais tout à l'heure la médecine préventive. On n'investit pas assez et ça, ce sont les organismes internationaux qui nous le disent.
Les pays voisins sont à 2,9 % en termes d'investissement dans la médecine préventive. On est seulement à 2 %. Ça ne fait pas mal aux gens, ça préserve absolument la qualité des soins, mais en mettant davantage de moyens dans la médecine préventive,
on évite beaucoup de coûts.
Et donc il s'agira avant tout d'être plus efficace, sachant qu'effectivement, c'est vraiment une question de responsabilité par rapport aux générations futures.
J'ai donc pu interviewer de nombreux politiciens ces derniers mois et malheureusement, ils m'ont indiqué un petit peu la même chose, c'est-à-dire : on va faire plus avec moins.
On va réorganiser pour moins dépenser et pouvoir libérer des budgets pour l'une ou l'autre priorité. Mais donc, si finalement tout le monde dit la même chose, comment est-ce qu'on sait pour qui voter ?
Mais clairement, nous, on a indiqué nos priorités. Nous, notre priorité, ce sera soulager fiscalement les entrepreneurs.
Ce sera également revaloriser les bas salaires pour pouvoir avoir un incitant à l'activation, pour mettre davantage de personnes à l'emploi.
Je pense qu'on a un très grand nombre de personnes qui ne sont pas à l'emploi actuellement. Il y a également des malades de longue durée pour lesquels il faudra avoir des mesures tout à fait ciblées.
On est bien conscient qu'il y a des personnes qui ne sont pas directement activables. Ça, c'est une évidence. Il faut avoir un point d'attention à des questions comme la santé mentale, le burn-out, etc.
Mais on voit bien qu'il y a des personnes qui peuvent être activées si on leur propose un job intéressant et qui est mieux corrélé avec leurs compétences.
Il faut aussi travailler sur
la formation continue. Moi, j'ai été une ministre extrêmement heureuse de l'enseignement de promotion sociale, qui remet à l'emploi des gens qui ont raté le premier train de la formation en faisant des validations de compétences sur le,
sur le terrain.
Par exemple, en cas de licenciement collectif, eh bien, on peut avoir des petites cellules de l'enseignement de promotion sociale qui viennent sur le terrain pour
certifier une compétence particulière d'un travailleur pour qu'il puisse trouver un emploi par la suite.
Voilà, c'est vraiment faire en sorte qu'il y ait davantage de sécurité pour la personne qui décide de changer d'emploi. Donc, on a dans notre programme un droit à la démission, par exemple, mais aussi une,
un incitant à pouvoir se former pour pouvoir se reconvertir dans un autre,
dans un autre secteur professionnel.
Ça, je pense que c'est vraiment capital et c'est comme ça qu'on va créer davantage de plus-values, de recettes pour l'État.
Donc d'ailleurs, je pense que dans quelques heures, on va voir les résultats du Bureau fédéral du Plan par rapport à l'analyse de notre programme.
Je pense que vous aurez une surprise positive en ce qui nous concerne. Et je pense qu'on va vraiment, avec ces mesures, créer un saut de PIB et également un saut d'activation de nouveaux emplois.
Et je pense que c'est comme ça, en ayant davantage de personnes qui vont pouvoir contribuer, qu'on pourra préserver notre modèle, notre modèle de soins de santé, également préserver nos pensions.
Ça, c'est effectivement le grand défi. Et donc, je suis heureuse que d'autres personnes que moi vous aient parlé de ça, parce qu'il ne faut pas raconter des carabistouilles aux électeurs.
Il faut vraiment leur tenir un langage de sérieux, pas aller leur promettre n'importe quoi. La promesse en politique, quand elle est galvaudée, c'est terrible le résultat.
Vous parliez tout à l'heure de lutter contre les extrêmes. Moi, j'incite vraiment les électeurs à aller regarder ce que dit le Bureau fédéral du Plan par rapport aux promesses des partis.
Donc, effectivement, le constat, pour revenir à la question de la justice, le constat, c'est qu'actuellement, au pénal, par exemple, un procès peut attendre deux ans.
Et puis, l'accusé, s'il est jugé coupable, peut faire appel et ça prend de nouveau deux ans. J'ai même parfois pu entendre parler d'affaires qui étaient traînées sur vingt ans.
Est-ce que, enfin, puisque voilà, le MR est quand même au pouvoir au fédéral depuis...
Ben oui, depuis au moins vingt ans sans interruption. Comment est-ce qu'on peut à la fois dire que le MR va favoriser la justice et le financement de la justice et en même temps, faire le constat que-
Mais je vous réponds très clairement. Moi, j'ai été ministre pendant quatre ans en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, ministre des Maisons de justice. Et on a revu,
on a engagé, je ne sais plus le nombre exact, mais plus d'une cinquantaine de personnes pour faire exécuter les peines de moins de trois ans et pouvoir aussi
développer les peines alternatives et pouvoir faire en sorte qu'il y ait moins de sentiment d'impunité par rapport à la population.
Donc, ce ne sont pas des fantasmes. Je vous parle ici de budgets que nous avons débloqués et qui ont permis l'engagement de personnes, qui est toujours en cours, je pense, mais l'engagement est en cours.
Donc, les budgets ont été débloqués. Donc, il y a effectivement davantage de personnes qui peuvent
faire exécuter les peines de moins de trois ans au niveau des assistants de justice, qui peuvent respecter que les conditions d'une libéralisation, d'une,
d'une libération conditionnelle sont bien respectées.
Donc, ce n'est pas du vent, ça, hein, c'est quelque chose de concret.
Les délais restent très longs.
Alors bien sûr, je n'ai pas dit qu'on allait tout régler du jour au lendemain,
mais en tant que ministre des Maisons de justice, nous avons vraiment assuré une diminution du nombre de peines qui n'étaient pas exécutées, de peines alternatives en particulier, qui n'étaient pas exécutées.
Oui. Mais donc c'est particulier puisque à la fois, vous défendez le fait que les libéraux, donc autant l'Open VLD que le Mouvement Réformateur, est le parti de la justice.
Et en même temps, c'était justement le parti, l'Open VLD, qui était donc au ministère de la Justice fédérale-
Mais je n'ai pas de problème à vous dire que je suis très fière que l'Open VLD ait renforcé le parquet de Bruxelles. Alors, c'est insuffisant, il faut continuer.
Et je n'ai jamais dit non plus que nous étions seuls autour de la table. Il y a encore du travail à faire. Ça, c'est une évidence aussi, mais je ne pense pas que nous ayons à rougir.
Moi, en tout cas, en tant que ministre des Maisons de justice, nous estimons que nous avons fait de notre mieux pour faire exécuter les peines de moins de trois ans, oui.
Et on a mis les moyens pour cela.
Valérie Glatigny, on va bientôt devoir se quitter. Je voulais aborder un dernier sujet, peut-être un peu plus inconnu du grand public avec vous.
Vous me faites peur.
Attendez, vous n'êtes pas prête. Vous avez été, dans votre jeunesse, joueuse de batterie.
Oui.
Et donc, et c'est d'ailleurs comme ça-
Qui a cafté ?
J'ai écouté vos interviews précédentes. Donc c'est vous.
Je me souviens pas avoir dit ça. Je viens de le dire en off, alors. Parce que je suis nulle. J'aimais beaucoup, mais je suis pas très douée.
Ah oui, d'accord. Mais donc, est-ce que, première question très anecdotique, est-ce que vous avez fait partie d'un groupe de rock, alors ?
Oui, un petit groupe de rock qui a pas duré très longtemps, mais quand j'étais étudiante, on a eu beaucoup de plaisir, oui.
Mais je n'avais pas d'avenir comme batteuse.
Oui, OK. C'est dans ce contexte-là que, voilà, vous êtes devenue malentendante ? Est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui a guidé votre action politique également ?
Oui, c'était pas lié à ça, mais j'ai eu un petit problème de santé, mais effectivement, le fait que j'ai un problème d'audition me rend probablement plus sensible à toute une série de
personnes qui sont en souffrance physique.
Oui, ça, je pense que c'est... Nous sommes des êtres humains et donc, il faut pouvoir se rappeler aussi que la politique, on fait de la politique aussi avec son corps et que quand on n'est pas en capacité de le faire,
être ministre, par exemple, c'est pas un métier, c'est une mission.
Et pour remplir cette mission que d'autres nous donnent, notamment les électeurs, ben il faut être à cent pour cent de ses capacités.
Et donc, voilà, pouvoir tirer les conséquences quand on n'est pas en capacité de le faire, revenir quand on l'est, mais effectivement, se souvenir que nous sommes tous des êtres humains.
Et donc, par exemple, le fait que j'aimerais siéger en commission santé n'est pas complètement décorrélé de ce que j'ai pu expérimenter.
Mh. Est-ce que vous avez le sentiment qu'il y a des choses qui sont mal comprises vis-à-vis du handicap, des a priori que les gens peuvent avoir, des incompréhensions de... ?
Oui, j'ai été étonnée de voir le nombre de gens qui m'envoyaient des petits messages pour dire qu'ils étaient contents que j'aie dit que j'étais appareillée auditivement.
Donc ça, c'est vrai que je m'attendais pas...
Une représentativité tout d'un coup en politique.
Oui, c'est ça. Alors que je-- En fait, je voulais dire à ces gens : « Mais il y en a plein. Simplement, ils ne le disent pas, mais nous sommes très nombreux.
Donc, n'ayez pas honte d'être appareillé. Assumez-le parce que c'est... Nous sommes très nombreux. »
Valérie Glatigny, merci beaucoup.
Merci à vous.
C'était Septante Minutes et à très bientôt pour un nouvel épisode.
À bientôt.
Voilà, sauf imprévu, c'était la dernière interview politique de cette saison. J'espère que ça vous a plu et que ça vous aura permis de peut-être former une opinion.
Je ferai peut-être bien d'ailleurs une petite rétrospective sur toutes ces interviews politiques et de ce que j'en ai retenu.
Peut-être après les élections, je ne sais pas, on verra.
En tout cas, avant de se quitter, petit fact check, puisque comme le disait Valérie Glatigny, les chiffrages du Bureau fédéral du Plan sont sortis ce mardi, donc vraiment juste après notre rencontre.
Pour rappel, c'est l'organe de l'État qui s'occupe, entre autres, de chiffrer les promesses de campagne pour qu'on puisse objectiver un petit peu les différents discours.
Le rapport est assez indigeste, pour être honnête, et c'est assez difficile à lire, mais on a pu compter sur la presse. Je pense notamment à Nathan Scherlings pour Le Vif, pour, voilà, pour nous aider à s'y retrouver.
Et il ressort, n'en déplaise à mon invitée, que selon le Bureau fédéral du Plan, ce n'est pas du tout le Mouvement Réformateur qui est le meilleur élève en termes de rigueur budgétaire.
Ce qui est pourtant, voilà, une des grandes promesses des libéraux, historiquement. Pour ce qui est du déficit budgétaire, le MR est en fait en bas du classement avec un déficit budgétaire de sept point six pour cent.
Et ce sont la N-VA et le PS qui arrivent en tête avec trois virgule six et quatre virgule cinq pour cent respectivement.
Pour rappel donc, l'Europe, l'Union européenne demande à ce qu'on arrive à équilibrer le budget, qu'on arrive à un déficit budgétaire de maximum trois pour cent.
Voilà, on en avait beaucoup parlé avec Philippe Lamberts il y a quelques mois.
Et même chose pour la dette publique, puisque la N-VA arrive en tête, suivie du PS et du PTB, avec le Vlaams Belang et le Mouvement Réformateur en dernière position.
Ça s'explique de plusieurs manières différentes. Le PS arrive si haut parce qu'en fait, c'est lui qui compte, semble-t-il, taxer le plus les riches,
alors que pour la N-VA, c'est parce qu'ils veulent couper à fond dans les aides sociales de leur côté.
Inversement, le MR veut relever la quotité exemptée d'impôts pour arriver au niveau du revenu d'intégration sociale, ce qui représente évidemment un énorme manque à gagner.
Et puis, deuxièmement, ils veulent aussi, au Mouvement Réformateur, augmenter les salaires nets des travailleurs en supprimant notamment la cotisation spéciale de Sécurité sociale.
Mais voilà, comme on le disait dans l'interview, comme je le disais dans l'interview, si on refuse la fiscalité, ça passe inévitablement par de l'endettement et c'est ce qui transparaît dans, ben voilà, le rapport du Bureau fédéral du Plan.
Voilà, donc c'était un petit fact check par rapport à la rigueur budgétaire dont se vantait mon invitée, Valérie Glatigny, pendant l'interview.
Et ensuite, deuxième petit fact check plus anecdotique, c'est que c'est en fait Thomas Dermine et Pierre-Yves Dermagne que Georges-Louis Bouchez avait attaqués en disant,
je cite : « Moi, par contre, je ne sais pas ce qu'il fait Thomas Dermine, ainsi que
quand je demande ce que fait Pierre-Yves Dermagne de ses journées, c'est sincère.
» Voilà, ce sont des petites quotes de Georges-Louis Bouchez. Parce qu'après tout, voilà, pourquoi choisir ?
En fait, il avait critiqué les deux. Enfin, on n'en a pas parlé pendant l'interview, mais il existe un site pour répertorier toutes les aides auxquelles ont droit les étudiants en précarité.
Je vous mets le lien en description, c'est www.aides-études.be. On se retrouve très bientôt. Salut salut !